coronavirus infection rates are on the
rise across the world and the global
kovid 19 death toll is now over 700 000.
in germany thousands including far-right
groupings have protested
against anti-corona hygiene rules like
masks and social distancing
they believe that their freedom is under
threat from government regulations
meanwhile in germany and elsewhere fears
of what will happen
when holiday makers return home and
children return to school
so on to the point we asked coronavirus
second wave
scare mongering or real danger
[Music]
well thanks very much indeed for joining
us here in the studio today
my three guests include yulia fisher
former doctor and now journalist and
author
she says we must make no compromises in
implementing the lessons learned so far
if not the second wave will be very very
painful
she says also with this is ulrika
hermann business and finance
journalist with the berlin-based daily
the target site or d-tats
and eureka believes that by the fall the
late
at the latest corona will be back and
she warns the economy will be hard
hit and a very warm welcome to tobias
quartz professor
of public health and epidemiology at
berlin charity hospital
he says we must do everything in our
power to keep infection rates
low and protect the public sector
thank you all for being here once again
i'd like to begin with you tobias curt
and until very recently there was a
sense here in germany that we had the
situation with the coronavirus
uh pretty much under control it's fair
to say so is it fair to ask
what has gone wrong i'm not sure
something went wrong
i think the the slight rise that we're
seeing right now was expected because we
open the borders we allow people to
travel
abroad where people maybe behave
something
somewhat different than they would do at
home they come back some of them are
infected
the schools are opening public life is
opening which is
a good thing i i think the the issue
that we see over the last days is a
certain rise in
in the numbers as well the numbers are
up yes but
we're on a very low level still so it's
there's an increase
and if this is a really big wave that we
that we're seeing right now
we have to wait and we have to everyone
really take control
on that infection rate wearing masks
keeping that distance so we can keep the
public life open that's really important
julia you're not inc yeah i'm i totally
agree because i also think that it's not
surprising that the numbers are coming
up um
the robot core institute says um parts
of it
is due to the uh to to parties that are
happening in
in private places with families so it's
strange isn't it for viewers uh
outside germany or outside berlin
specifically it will seem strange that
we talk about corona parties here in
berlin
yeah yeah the ones i was talking about
right now are not corona parties i would
say but it's
people getting together and having
little gatherings or bigger gatherings
than were allowed a few weeks
ago and i mean i think it's normal that
the numbers are going to rise after
having more
parties or get togethers more gatherings
like that
but that we can still react to it and
that we still have it under control
we're not being hit by a wave yet
it might develop to a wave but we're not
there yet
angela merkel always warns against that
she uses the german word of course she
uses the word lights in each kite which
means sort of complacency
it appears to me and to many other
observers to be dreadful
complacency your your your response
gives me
the notion that it's sort of all part of
human nature
it is part of human nature we've been in
a time that was hard on us
it's a burden for everybody having to
live in
in this situation not knowing when it's
going to end
living a life that's not like the life
we used to and that causes stress and
that makes it hard for us to to keep to
the rules but
still of course we have to stick to the
rules and we have to keep going
but it is part of human nature that we
have
that we want to end this and that we get
especially if we don't see the numbers
rising and
in summer we had a really calm time and
that's what we
um the the prevention paradox
is that that's yeah if you don't see the
numbers rising and the virus being
really really
um dangerous you might believe it's
already over and of course that's not
the case it's
natural to think this but we have of
course to tell the people it's not over
yet we really have
to keep taking the measures okay audrey
hermann the uh the authorities in
germany have been broadly praised for
the for the response to the crisis so
far
do you share in that praise well i think
that um
the german authorities reacted in the
right way
but it's not true and that's something
that the germans tend to think that it
was only german
a germany that was successful in
fighting the
pandemic for example a country that is
always overlooked and that was even more
successful than germany
is greece because greece stopped
carnival for example at the very
beginning whereas in germany we had big
parties at carnival with the ending with
lots of corona cases
so the greeks didn't have carnival they
stopped in
parties they stopped or they shut all
the russians down all the
shops down at a stage when the germans
were still
trying to act as if everything was
normal so well yes the germans were good
but they were not the only ones
successful in europe and to beast court
you are clearly worried from your
statement to the top of the show that
the health services in germany
could in the foreseeable future be
overstretched despite everything that
we've just been hearing
i was not talking only about the health
services but about public life as
a whole so so restaurants and the
economy
like concert halls like cinemas that we
can keep this open so we just
managed to open them up again and the
numbers were low and so we
really have to make efforts to keep them
open and we all can change
the numbers by wearing masks by keeping
the distance
and eventually hopefully we have
medication or vaccination available
that that really make a big difference
but until then we
we have to work together to prevent a
further lockdown
okay despite all that we've heard so far
some observers are talking about a
corona divide here in germany
and one half of that divide is the
growing number of people joining
protests against hygiene regulations
and claiming that fundamental freedoms
are at stake
the estimated crowd of 20 000 people who
demonstrated against compulsory masks
and other coronavirus restrictions last
weekend was an unusual mix
among them were coronavirus deniers
anti-vaxxers
right-wing extremists and conspiracy
theorists all united in their anger
against the federal government
their motto the end of the pandemic a
day
of freedom
they're just plain scare tactics i don't
see any danger i don't know any sick
people
our demand is basically going back to
democracy away with these laws that have
been imposed on us away with the masks
that make us slaves
people who don't do research the way we
do it they are kept stupid and believe
what the government tells us
and they buy into the fear that the
government peddles to us and fear
attacks the immune system
freedom or safety is this the choice
that defines the pandemic
julia fisher that's the big question
isn't it i mean we've all been following
the the
the debate here in berlin here in
germany uh that was triggered by the
that demonstration last weekend
is it public health against freedom is
that the the divide
the debate i don't think so um
or it's difficult to say i mean um and i
think
great parts of uh germany and the people
in germany understand that these
measures are needed
and that it's okay and that it's not
really our freedom being taken away from
us it's just a piece of cloth that we
have to wear in the face
but then there's also other people who
um who can't take the situation who are
being more stressed by it maybe and who
are trying
um to find an answer why this
situation is so difficult um to stand
and
that's why they're making up other
explanations
because yeah a lot of people clearly do
believe that democracy is in danger
uh and there are then the others you've
been explaining who
you know see the other side of the
argument uh one politician here in
germany talked of the people taking part
in these protesters
co-vidiates corona idiots yeah that was
pretty extreme stuff
surely we need to have more sympathy or
more understanding for people who and
their concerns i think
um it's you have to differentiate
between the people you have to see
the ones that are claiming um
difficulties with the situation that are
perfectly
um righteous that like
people want to see their friends meet
friends people want to work
people want um not having their
financial um
um they don't want to be destroyed
financially
and um all these things are
problems that we need to hear and we
need to talk to the people and explain
to them what is important but then
of course there's the ones um that it's
difficult to talk to because they have
complaints that are just
not right corona is a false
alarm what do you say to that it's not a
false alarm corona is real corona is
dangerous
and you can measure corona clearly and
if you say corona doesn't exist
then we're in a very dangerous situation
the the protest
the the mix of different groups are very
difficult
to to understand and actually there's
there's a danger in when you have
right-wing groups that have a certain
agenda and trying to use this momentum
and there are people as um
just just said who have real concerns
about the situation
who see that really we have low numbers
so obviously
not much is going on it's someone's
beautiful outside
and and not much is happening so why
can't i
so that's a normal reaction and in a
democracy
we should we should be able to discuss
this and we should
allow these voices to speak up and we
should openly discuss their concerns to
understand their concerns and jointly
really target their pandemic because we
can only do it jointly if
one group thinks that that way works and
the other are just idiots that is really
then dividing the population and we
should not do that
but it was interesting to know that
there were practically no
masks in sight in the berlin
demonstration that's
it feels like a form of sort of russian
roulette
i wouldn't be that extreme you
certainly risk getting infected whether
then you are actually getting sick it's
not a question
and and obviously you're risking that
you infect other people and then
they infect other people and so on so uh
i think it was not
a smart move to not wear a mask during a
demonstration where you were really
close together
but obviously there was one of the
reasoning to to not wear a mask
i think we all have to understand that
each of us can
make a difference and if we wear this
piece of cloth
for a couple more months and maybe then
select it so
airplanes for example or public
transportation asia
has distanced many many years that
people wear masks in public
transportation that's that's a normal
situation there
maybe that's a new normal for us and if
you wear this for a couple of minutes or
a couple of hours
i don't think that your freedom is in
danger but ulrich
what do you do with people who do refuse
to work to wear masks mainly men
yes that's exactly the case i mean
that's something that we also
note in our newspaper that we get
letters by men
who always uh complain
that they have to wear muscle but they
are not allowed to celebrate their 17th
birthday or whatever
so yes i think that you should just find
them i think that
it is important to talk to people but i
think it's also
important to show that the state has
authority
because those who always complain about
their freedom
if you look at their personality usually
it's people who
somehow crave authority and they
react positively to authority they just
want to see
where the line is i mean it's exactly
those people
not all of them but many who vote for
right-wing parties
so they want to have as we just say in
german a furore
a no thought authoritarian person so
i think in a way it's good if the state
or the government just shows
how the rules are um you'll official
what would your response be to people
who
simply refused to wear masks i was i
mean i came in to do the show today and
i was sitting opposite a guy
who didn't wasn't wearing a mask at all
or it was
halfway down his chest well you know
what do you do do you address people do
you
pull people up what's um that's
difficult i would always
um i think i would decide
in the moment if if i think the the one
is open for for debating and talking or
um like in the subway for example maybe
i would just let him
let him pass but i would always try um
as a science journalist to address the
people and to really explain why masks
are important that they are
the one important measure that we have
do you think it's okay to find them that
they have to pay 150
euros i think that's fair i think it's i
think it's fair
in the subway and in supermarkets when
you know you can't keep
the distance i think it's okay to do so
in order to make the people have the
people know
that their actions have effect
it's interesting i was talking to a
friend of mine from from thailand who
was saying that in large parts of
asia what we were just saying that uh
it's a
it's a real affront to other people's
well-being uh he he actually used he
used quite often he said it's like
urinating in the corner
it's that extreme but we sort of for
some reason
more or less success it's a difference
of mentality somehow and
a difference of being used to things
that are um
polite and that are normal to do in a
society in in asia it's
way more it's polite and it's normal to
do so and we still need to get
used to it i think we can but it still
needs some time
just about these protests before we move
on to a different matter
how typical are there is there something
specifically german about the protests
um i wouldn't think so um the last
pandemics we had over the last century
you always have these voices and you
always have a protest
more or less obvious and you always have
people who have their theories about the
virus about the pandemic and about the
reaction how the government react and so
on um
so in in germany we are used to
go out and and uh state our opinion and
that's a good thing and
and and so to having this particular
demonstration
is is also i wouldn't say normal but was
expected and i'm sure will happen again
and and so i think it's important to to
keep up the discussion while
uh obviously we also need to make sure
that
the minimal measures that we have to
take wearing masks
i don't think it's about a mask i think
it's about a system trying to tell you
what you have to do
and wearing a mask is more or less easy
sometimes getting uncomfortable after
hours if you wear glasses a little bit
difficult but
i don't think it's about a mask and in a
way you know it was just
20 000 people and here in berlin we have
four million inhabitants
so in a way it was a very small minority
and they came from all parts of
germany so the awards and all people who
live in berlin but they all gathered
okay we will continue to monitor the
situation now around the world lockdowns
have certainly had a devastating
economic impact many countries are still
struggling to recover including in
southern europe particularly spain
it is a clearance sale and although
inigo crespo has already drastically
reduced his prices
few customers come to buy anything or
even able to buy anything
yesterday i made 102 euros at most
honestly i don't know how long we can
survive with these prices
crespo has already had to close one of
his three stores
the spanish economy suffered an 18.5
slump in the second quarter
while the average across europe was a
solid 12 percent
a historic drop now shopkeepers like
inigo crespo fear a renewed increase in
the number of infections
because another lockdown would be his
ruin
can europe's economy survive a second
coronavirus wave
it's a big question we're asking a lot
of eureka but that is the question can
economies like spain survive a second
wave well spain can only survive if it's
being helped by the other european
countries because you know unfortunately
in europe we have this divide between
poor countries like
let's say spain or portugal or greece
and rich countries like germany
for example for germany it was no
problem to survive corona so far because
all what the government did was just to
print new money by
taking out loans and there's no limit
for the german government when it comes
to
taking out loans but for those poor
countries it's really difficult to get
finance so what we need is that all of
europe
agrees on a package it has already been
proposed
and it's around 750 billion euros that
are supposed to be
voted for in parliament and then to go
to the poor countries and it's really
very important that this package of 750
billion euros
is um agreed on and decided on and then
perhaps the situation in spain can be
alleviated
what about the role of people like us
ordinary citizens in germany and in the
rest of europe what should we be doing
i mean consume consume consumer
you should go out out and buy as much as
you can i mean it's
you know from a from a vantage point of
a
environment it's of course horrible but
that we have to consume but in order to
save the economy
it's the best thing to do people need to
go out and shop and not stay at home and
not stay at home and worry
yeah well that's
basically it yeah but i asked big
questions about the future of our
economy because people are
you know the the the economies are
slowing down that's the
that's the essential message here yeah
yes of course and uh it will take a long
time for the economy
to recover uh for um well
germany for example just um had a
decline of 10 percent in the second
quarter
it was not as bad as spain that had 18
but nonetheless 10 percent
is a lot and it will take a whole of
2021
in order to somehow get uh to get back
on track
and what about the global economy
meanwhile i mean that's you know sort of
it's all interconnected it's all so
funny
it's all slowing down and especially you
know it's hardly
possible to somehow see what will be
happening in the united states because
they
do not get the pandemic and the control
so probably they will have a second look
down and that of course is very bad news
for the whole of
the world because the united states is
one of the most important customers for
example for the german economy
so it's really very difficult to see
what will happen um
to bs i made a i made a a little list of
the countries that are
that are struggling the most at the
present i mean so many countries are
struggling usa japan morocco hong kong
australia i could go on obviously
you know what public health measures do
the do
does the global community have moving
into the future now
what new measures what new proposals
it's very difficult to answer is on the
global
scale so each region has just specific
settings a specific healthcare system
a specific economy specific uh social
psychological systems
uh so it's uh it's really difficult to
say what
we all can do certainly what we have to
try to do is get the numbers under
control
and and so uh important also for germany
to to keep on going
and to not advice but but really tell
other countries
how it may work and the who obviously
has
has experts who who can assist
but but often people don't listen and
and the
initial epidemic was not taken seriously
so i would say that was just a
little flu virus and and so let him come
and
and and obviously now they've suffered
the most these countries other countries
they have a different setup in terms of
having no resources to actually do
something
so it's very difficult for them to
actually react and do
they simply can't afford it they cannot
afford it and people living conditions
working conditions living conditions
at home are very difficult and
challenging and and increase the
likelihood of getting infected
so there is there is a search a certain
social
gradient where you have so those in the
lower end are more likely to getting
infected and those countries who have
less resources are more likely to having
a big issues and then you have countries
like the united states
and and others who have enormous
resources but they just didn't want to
react
so it's a mix of both and we have to
understand
that the globe is important also for the
economy like like if in germany all as
well we export a lot if the others don't
buy
then we also have a problem so we need
to help other countries
in europe and elsewhere to really get
the numbers of infection
under control just one quick word from
you that in the last couple of days
there's been a new tool
that has been talked about as a contact
diary for possibly moving forward into
the winter months
uh what just give us uh an idea of what
that's all about that sounds quite
interesting yeah you pretty much write
down with whom you are in context pretty
much the idea of often of an app i'm i'm
not so convinced also the app is is a
great idea
but uh it only works with a smartphone
and it only works on the smartphones of
the newest generation
so those who are at high risk of getting
infected those who cannot afford it
cannot use it so we have to find ways
and maybe the diary works but
um i i can't really see how it really
helps to
control the situation it will help
specifically if you say do do
did you write down with whom you had a
contact so you help
the the public health officials to
retrace other people
um but it's it's uh it will remain
difficult
um julia fischer how do we learn to live
with the crisis that is ongoing that's
been with us for six months now as you
mentioned earlier but it's not it's not
going away how do we learn
to live with it um we have to learn to
live with
with it we have to get used to it we
have to accept that it's a stressful
situation and that it's going to be hard
for everyone
but that if we all work together we can
keep
the the injuries small
we can try to um to identify the
clusters
and to isolate clusters so that we um
meaning groups of people that get
infected and that are a risk of
for spreading the disease so we have to
really go to those clusters and isolate
those
and that way we could keep the measures
low
for the rest of the public and that is
an aim i think that we should all work
for
i'm looking forward to using what we've
learned
to make the life that's ahead um
more normal the more normal we can there
is something out there however called
response fatigue how worrying is that
that is worrying um i mean it's also
part of human nature
um because we're stressed and we can't
take that for a long time
it is difficult but all we can do is
keep telling the people that we have to
work together and that we have to watch
out for
one another that it's not only you it's
not myself that i have to be worried
about but
all the other people i think we can only
keep talking
keep explaining um also not judging on
the people
um but um talking to them and explaining
mm-hmm one final word go give give me a
very quick take on uh
what you expect are we going to get a
second wave
yes i'm sure we'll be getting a second
wave in autumn
but perhaps it will be possible to just
control it by identifying those clusters
and apart from that we just have to wait
for a vaccination
that's the big point isn't it thanks
very much for joining us here on to the
point today
i hope we've given you plenty of food
for thought if we have come back next
week until then bye bye
and cheers
[Music]
[Music]
you